[Music]
you
my name is Alex Kurt furred I'm a
financial advisor at Edward Jones and
team captain of Arturo Jones testing the
corporate chesley is an opportunity for
companies around the st. Louis area and
hopefully one day beyond to come and
compete at a world-class facility of
chess that we have here in st. Louis and
we decided to get a tournament around
that to where companies can play one
another compete in a friendly
competitive way and enjoy each other's
company as well
chess is important for a wide variety of
people because it helps with your
decision-making it will help with your
problem-solving being able to think long
term and have short term intermediate
steps can translate into all types of
different areas of life ever Jones chose
to compete in the corporate chesley as a
way that we can
have some fun camaraderie with other
companies that were associated with as
well as a way to for ourselves to be
able to build some some teamwork aspects
as we have as a company and again just
be able to come up with just a top-class
facility have some fun
[Music]
you
[Music]